so something slightly different with
today's computer file rather than
recording this in our usual location
this one was actually recorded in front
of a live studio audience as part of a
training exercise
um for other members of Staff in
computer science at Nottingham so we
hope you enjoy it it's got a slightly
different feel to it but if you hear
people laughing in the background
um they're laughing at me not the topic
so I thought today we'd continue on the
discussion we've had about compression
we did the video I did an overview and
we talked there about how we could
Define compression in terms of a model
how we actually model the data and in
terms of encoding how we represent that
data in terms of bits and we can change
the encoding we can use something like
Huffman encoding to compress it or we
talked about how we can change the model
to get better compression as well I want
to talk about that today I'm going to
look at my favorite compression
algorithm which is bzip 2. I mean how
sad is that to have a favorite
compression algorithm but I'm a computer
scientist so
B zip2 algorithm is based around What's
called the Brewers wheeler transform and
this was developed by a chap called Mike
Burroughs based on somewhere that she's
PhD supervisor had done David wheeler in
Cambridge he was over in digital at the
time and he went on to develop a search
engine called Ulta Vista for anyone
who's over the age of 25 you might
remember that as what we used to search
the internet before this young upstart
called Google came along to have a look
at the boroughs of either transform
because it's not necessarily the thing
that you would think that would actually
help with compression but when you
actually use it and particularly with a
couple of other things it actually gets
a really nice bit of compression going
let's look at a common English phrase
and I'm going to go with to b or not to
be this string if you were to use a
compression algorithm like run length
encoding wouldn't actually compress that
well we talked about run length encoding
in the previous video it's where you
have your symbols and rather than just
saying there's this symbol you say how
long that would occur for so in this
case there's one t there's one o there's
one space there's one B there's one e
and as we talked about the string has
got massively bigger it's expanded
rather than compressing it it doesn't
compress that well but things get
interesting if you actually sort the
string so if we were to sort this not
into alphabetical order but based on its
ASCII ordering so using the numbers that
represent the characters what we'd end
up with we've got one two three four
five spaces I'll draw them as
underscores just to make it clear and
then we'd have the letters in order
we've got no A's we've got the B so
there's one we've got another B there
there's two we've got some E's we've got
one e there we've got one e there so
we've got two e's what comes next in the
alphabet uh n we've got an N we've got
one two three four O's and we've got two
T's I think three T's when we get to
that point when we've sorted it we get
it to a form that is actually more
compressible by using something like run
length encoding we've now got five
spaces two B's two e's One n four O's
and three T's and we can compress that
very relatively nicely using run length
and coding does it matter you've missed
out on R uh and there's an r in there as
well
this would compress really really well
as we said but there's a problem with it
if we've got this string there's no way
we can get it back to to be or not to be
because we've changed the ordering we no
longer have that information so we've
got a model that captures The Ordering
of the text which is what we're
interested in really because we want to
be able to read Hamlet possibly
um or we've got an encoding which or a
model rather which throws away all that
information but gives us the letters
is there something that we can do in
between
that gets us to a point which is really
compressible
but actually still gets us to a point
where we can keep the information that
we're on the text during the ordering
and this is where the boroughs we either
transform comes in so let's pick a
slightly simpler example to start with
because I really don't have to write it
out to be or not to be too many times so
I can use this word as an example to see
how the boroughs wheeler transform Works
what you do is you start off writing
down the data you want to encode I'm
using text here but you could use any
data for this and you just on the first
line write it out as it is
and then on the next line you rotate it
to the left by one so we start off with
o m p whoops that's a p obviously
t-u-t-e-r-p-h-i-l-e and then we put that
c that's fallen off the left hand side
on the end
and we keep doing that until we get back
to where we started from now I could do
this by hand and we'd be here until
Christmas so I've written a computer
program to do it for me so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to take the
word computer file I'm going to send it
into the program that I have written and
I'm going to get it to generate the
complete Boris wheeler transform for us
and what we end up with so this Matrix
this table where we have all the letters
rotated around until we've done it 13
times and we end up with the last one
where we've got the e at the beginning
and the rest of the word follows that
now why is that useful you might think
well how's that going to help us
compress what we do is we take that
table and we sort it based on ASCII
ordering and if we do that if we sort it
we end up with the list below
and on the left hand side in the left
hand column because we've sorted it we
end up with the words and the characters
that we saw before the sorted form as we
got when we did to b or not to be we're
getting exactly the same here c e e h i
l m o p p r to you again we've lost all
the information there we're not
interested now what we're interested in
is what's in the last column because
once we've sorted it if we take that
last column we can regenerate the
complete data that we started with how
does that work well let's switch back
to the example if we sort it and we take
that last column
e-l-t-p-h-i-o-c-r-m-e-up and sort that
again
what we end up with is c e e h Etc that
we had before so if we take the last
column as we said we can regenerate the
First Column because we can sort it so
we can get the c e e h now
if we pair them together and I've got to
write this on the paper now we get
e which is the character in The Last
column that we started with first
character and C which is a character
from The First Column we get L and we
get e and we get T and we get e to cut a
longer story short if we actually look
at what we've got E C appears on the
second line that we've got here we can
regenerate the whole of the first two
columns by pairing up what we saved the
last column and the sorted version of
that we can regenerate the whole of the
first two columns and if we sort that
again
we can pair that up with the last column
again and eventually we can build up the
whole table
now why is that useful for compression
it's actually useful for a whole load of
things it's used for compression it's
used for string searching it's used for
genomics all sort of things make you
through this transform but in terms of
compression why is that useful
well to do that we need to go back to a
longer example so we are going to go
back to Hamlet's Soliloquy but I'm not
going to
type it in by hand I've got it in a file
there I'm going to feed this through the
program
and I'm going to run it into the bwt
foam this time I'm not going to generate
the whole table I'm only going to
generate the last column and what's
interesting once we've done this and
once we've sorted it and we take the
last column
is that what we end up with is that we
have whole load of runs
of characters which are the same so
we've got ooo there we've got n n n n
here we've got n and then a bit later on
in there we've got lots of cheese so by
running it through the Boris we either
transform if we take the last column we
not only get something that we can use
to regenerate the whole original data we
can run it through that algorithm to
decompress it but we also get something
which has lots of characters that are
consecutive which you can run through
the Run length encoding routine to
compress down to a smaller step now the
interesting thing is why that actually
happens and we can see that if we
actually look at both the beginning and
the end of the two columns and we pick
an example I'm going to look at the
lines that begin with the letters h e so
on the left hand side the first 10
characters or so are the Matrix and then
on the right hand side we've got the
last few characters in The Matrix
because it is 525 characters long and my
screen's not big enough each of these
lines at the beginning that begin h e
they all end with t and the reason that
is is because if we think about it we
built up this matrix by rotating the
characters to the left one step and then
rotating to the left another step and
that gave us each of the things so each
of the ones where H E begins at the
beginning of that the character that was
before it let's come over onto the right
hand side
and then what we've got words like the
which begin with a t and then have h e
following them or there or there with a
ir and so on they'll all end up sorting
into the same spot which is what we've
got them here and of course because they
all had a t that preceded them that's
ended up on the right hand side so that
right hand column actually has whole
runs of common characters because we're
actually not compressing random data
we're compressing data that actually has
meaning and has structure in this case
it's English language grammar if it was
something else it would have its own
structure with it as well and so by
using this and then coupling it with a
few other things where they don't encode
the actual ASCII codes they rearrange
the table after each character we can
actually get to a really nice
compression algorithm which is used all
over the Internet B zip2 for compressing
files for Distributing things on Unix
systems and in other places as well but
it's also really nice example as we said
at the beginning of how by changing the
model you'd never want to use the Boris
wheeler transform to storing tax you
never want to have your word document or
your latex document represented in the
Boris wheeler transform it would be a
nightmat edit your computer would be
slow because you have to repurpose it
into the reading order to actually
access it but actually to compress it we
get an A version of the document a model
of the text that is much more
compressible so by changing the model as
well as changing the encoding we can end
up with a really good compression
algorithm
to our one space One S one U One n two
it gets massively bigger this sort of
encoding what's commonly referred to as
the top of the file with pointers to
where all these words occurred and if in
doubt use the pointers for repeats